[Music]
in subpods news Oh poop pod submitted by
Erica loves Joe Thank You Erica a man
searched through his own poop after
accidentally swallowing his ear pod well
how do you accidentally swallow how do
you do that does he eat like a duck is
that what he does he just goes shakes
what in the world
yep so this guy he's from Taiwan so I
don't know you tell me bright new year
pupils
sounds like a Taiwanese behavior dad you
probably just wanted his ear pods to
match the smell to stinky tofu how much
just shut it out so it smells good his
poop was like I can't hear broke what
he's like I mean I want can't speak
broke I want to play this motivational
thing about life and I want my heart to
hear it so he swallowed it so his heart
could hear it right there what am I
still playing music in his body through
the his intestines do that air pot had
to go through all of his intestines are
they water resistant [ __ ] I mean I don't
know so this happened here so he says
that you fell asleep he's still gonna
use it after I got going so you fell
asleep with his ear pods in and then
woke up and he couldn't find one the
right one and then so he used to find my
ear pods feature this is going
everywhere with him we have show that he
was it was that big room as him and so
he was like well [ __ ] like it says it's
prettier I can't find it anywhere and so
he was like looking under his blanket
like oh my god and then it's so [ __ ]
funny yes so then he could hear the beep
beep sound
I would imagine though he's searching
through his [ __ ] but it's like on the
floor underneath the bench
hear the beep so he was walking around
his whole room and the beep was
following him [ __ ] where is it that's
what you that a certain point ok but I
don't care I would do that but what
happened so and that's of you realize
well he swallowed it when he fell asleep
so I don't know how that huddle it still
had like life in his stomach is amazing
he's sleeping it fell like these maybe
he snores like you Joe he had a food
dream or he just went I'm hungry
this guy must be good at swallowing
pills I think it's big isn't it it's
pretty big and they confirm that the air
pod wasn't holy [ __ ]
can you imagine I don't I can't make it
out it's this oh I got doctor eyes I
know you do you know what doctors are
explain the x-ray and I don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about
I just know the airport shape they
showed you take on the thing do you see
that's your baby
that's a friends episode with Rachel she
can't tell that it's her baby and she
just pretend that it is exactly what it
is crying I won't lie the first time I
pretended like I knew where he was
because you can't tell and they use like
big words like oh and this is from
sagittal plane you know oh yeah but then
the other one is bright you can see him
a little more develop but the first one
you showed relax a like this one so then
he ditched it and found it medicine why
would he take a picture oh my god I
found a
lifting through his [ __ ] how did he know
which [ __ ] wait why is it you any [ __ ]
in the toilet
why didn't he [ __ ] in a bowl that's true
but I don't know I mean they have those
squatting toilets oh guy
it doesn't like a squat oh looks like
it's in the floor how did he know it
would be that [ __ ] how many times did he
dig initial exited after he went to the
hospital they gave him a laxative and
they told him he wanted her your shits
because if you can't get it out then
you're gonna we're gonna have to perform
surgery on you and that was the first
[ __ ] that he had why what did this
stupid [ __ ] wear [ __ ] gloves
holy [ __ ] farts evil yeah dude but
you're telling me you would touch your
own shoe I know you you would buy gloves
you know I wouldn't buy gloves if I
needed it and then so he was like
filming it if it was if it was jewelry
I'd go right but air pots I don't think
you would God let it I'd flush it but he
had to find it humanity surgery yes
beans Matt what does that smasher call I
would like the [ __ ] you space I've ever
seen in my life never seen somebody so
goofy in my life it was used for yeah
it's a potato masher I thought it was
for being the only the potatoes are just
shaking their head toll for a second I
was like what does this bean smash are
you speaking of potatoes mash I was like
what the [ __ ] no masher masher good turn
for like a racist that hates Mexicans
bean smasher that's a wrestler name yeah
actually and so he was saying that he
looks like he's about to smoke it oh god
his [ __ ] hands make me get he looks
like a racist drying
like have a white person drew an Asian
person that's what they look like it's
like the racist and his shoulders look
really small pretty tonight he has a
good psycho body right I mean he does
look like a the kind of guy I would
freaking eat some airports skin though
that's why people call Asians aliens man
we just look like aliens with hair I
could take a picture smile like that
with poop all right all right [ __ ]
covered as I find was it rain is here he
was really shocked that the air pods
still work it was 41% they have free
health care because that's who's gonna
go to the hospital again for offensive
really good it's really fast that's why
they don't have any preventive care like
[ __ ] watch wear gloves don't put [ __ ]
in your ears it's crazy yeah like
there's there's there specialized
medicine is whack but like if you have
like a sprain or whatever a cold regular
medicine is really good just go there's
a hospital like a private hospital every
[ __ ] corner hm and you show up and
you're in and out no matter what it is
in like 15 minutes
even if you need 20 shots you go in and
today it's not it's not like slow like
the DMV it's like once you get a number
there's already a window calling you're
going there a doctor comes it's really
good SoDo oh yeah so he was saying that
they should include his story in the
next advertisement campaign for it no I
would not buy the entire human digestive
system that's impressive though I'm out
still working not with that face dude he
can't sell nothing it out play it again
yeah so the doctor was saying that
because of the plastic shell around the
air pod it it saved him from causing a
lot of harm like it wouldn't cut
anything cuz it's a yeah or like even
just exposure to the battery
oh but because of the plastic covering
like
Chris's stomach acid didn't eat it at
all no y'all have earplugs use
headphones sans I hate the dongle though
what's a dongle oh I do that I guess to
do wireless ones too but the dongle that
goes on your like that I can you bet it
attaches to the the flower Jack yeah it
makes regular headphones be able to plug
into our phones it's annoying
yeah I just use the Bose one Bose I love
it
and it you don't have to charge it what
is it bluetooth yes if I swallow in that
one yeah I can't find it they're
wireless yeah they're awesome I mean ice
castle I use the beats ones when I run
you're so hip hop but don't you like the
thing on the side where you could
control the volume and stuff so that's
why I prefer that one
yes you don't have war it's like beating
it don't know why we're pod so big like
they blew the [ __ ] up
like what wouldn't that mean that was
like I don't speak broke or whatever the
I'm butchering it this is a terrible
mean that's awful and it was funny I'm
awful are they expensive
I don't got her 50 bucks so the whole
the whole thing was like it was the same
time that Apple changed the headphone
jack so you had to buy special apple
headphones and so they were selling air
pause and it's like don't worry we got
you for $150 people would like I just
saw everybody with the air pot in their
ear and they just look like unfits like
broken it's like broken earbuds that's
what it seems what come on looks so
stupid I don't like that part of it you
do have some wireless ear thingies but
they're not ear plugs but there is just
like a circle thing yeah man and I would
lose one you would because I lost three
of them so I I would always have one
side and I know I lost like you know the
wireless buds I bought like few
different brands like I had a I lost the
Bose one I lost this other off-brand one
it's an opera one so just like
sunglasses I don't buy nice things
anymore
I'll see the beats when it goes around
your ear and then it has like a wire
that connects the two yeah those are
enduring
that's why I went back to the og baby
about make bluetooth headphones that
look like hearing it it's kind of like
that it goes around you know I wanted to
buy your medical apparatus in your ear
wiggly wire yeah yeah I think beats I
know my dad has like the color of your
ear dude I will hear dad was standing by
the door by the garage door I come in
and then he got scared cuz he didn't
hear me but the doors [ __ ] so I
opened it and I'm already talking to
typing he goes he goes like that and I
was like what the [ __ ] like you clearly
like you can hear me talking house gets
told he doesn't even listen to [ __ ] up
the thing that I hate the most is more
talking on the phone and he asked me a
question I'm crackin up and I have a
five minute explanation point that
you're quiet the whole time at what
begin it was an apt one what are you
doing here jack - wait you didn't hear
that's just your fault then cuz you
already know the way he so you should
just have checking in every sentence if
I do know I do that did you hear that
okay wait so does that mean that he's
going totally deaf cuz or he needs to
turn up that volume on his ear is he
good with like his site can he read
maybe we should just text him his site
it's pretty good there's our text oh oh
yeah is your dad alive and this whole
time I thought he just liked the sound
when he played the Chinese parade
because when I used to live there he
would have it on full volume and it's
like with Chinese parades happily just
wasn't haha
and he would watch this marching parade
like over and over and over
Lauda's and I was like oh there goes a
parade again
I love the national anthem or some [ __ ]
that's so [ __ ] funny